good morning carpe diem  fighting them cavities  you  day  beautiful  getting ready to see my girl she taken  forever though  what small food your pizza's here  damn cranberry what are you looking at  what what do you  anything about snapchat Jesus you need  to get a light are you following me  right now  I'm driving behind the snap driving and  driving give me that give me that  whoa this dude just pulled me in his  truck look I'm here to break you out is  a snapchat room  it was sober  it's 3 o'clock in the morning Justin  it's 3 o'clock in the morning I just  can't and you're doing this against open  up and with Zach no something happened  you gotta be kidding me I'm leaving you  know these tacos are boom  you